how are you good to see you okay canada
in person this is so cool this is some
personal it's so cool and can i just say
you have not missed a beat because the
way you hit that red carpet angles
really yeah you know how to work a
camera it has been a while since i've
been i've been that's a lie by the way
i've never been good at that
you were amazing no you really we filmed
it we have the footage we have the
evidence
i'm i suck at it
it's okay it's okay it is cool well
first of all your curls your your
character with these curls
are we going to get a perm like did your
fiance say khan i love the curls she
loved those she loved the hairline do
you have like this nice strong parallel
yeah
i don't have in real life but it's all
good
yeah you know and it at first i was like
i don't want to wear the wig we're not
just an extra hour in here and makeup
but then i saw it and i was like okay
wow
yeah and joel look his hair looks just
like the real guys yeah so you know
kudos to lawrence
for that yeah what attracted you to this
role like are you a true prime fan i am
i'm a huge dateline fan yes oh i really
am i mean this has been this has been
like my binky
for
25 26 years whatever how long this has
been on the air yeah there's something
about true crime murder mystery type
stuff
that i just love yeah and i find it
soothing really do you know why that is
i'm concerned
i really do i'll find this stuff this is
the kind of stuff that i'll put on
before i go to bed
maybe it makes me feel better about
myself knowing that i'm watching
terrible things other people did and
you're just a good person going to bed i
go to bed feeling like a good boy
what was your reaction your first
reaction when you saw renee's
transformation
i mean i wasn't surprised because the
girl was a total chameleon yeah she's
just an absolute beast when she attacks
when she approaches a role
um i've known her for many years yeah
and so she is
the main reason i wanted to do this to
be honest i love i just love her i love
her work to get a chance to work with
somebody that great
i love the script i love i've worked
with nbc for many years yeah
and it just and i knew about this story
i knew oh i knew because i'd seen it
yeah like i said i've seen the date line
forever and so there was there was all
these things that just felt like an
event it just felt like it might be
yeah
what do you think it is about pam that
people just kept getting it wrong
like how i don't know i asked the same
thing i think it was like this perfect
storm of
ineptitude
you know starting with the cops yeah
thought right away oh it's got to be the
husband it's always the husband and they
weren't gonna think any other
anybody else could have done it yeah and
then the da came on and she was like
well you know this is an opportunity for
me to make a name for myself
and then you have
this jury here
you got a judge who had no business
being up there and then it was just all
these things kind of came together
meanwhile my character comes in and says
wait a second
you got us you're not even going to look
at anybody else thank god for you well
thank god for joyce you know and and one
of the cool things about him is that he
was
a guy who represented people forever
that probably did do it
and so this was an opportunity when he
realized that he didn't actually do it
he's like wait a second
i'm getting this guy off yeah you know
and and
it was heartbroken after that first
trial when
when he was found guilty and and so he
was like a you know a dog in a bone
after that
yeah right yeah well it was so nice to
talk to you and like i mean you got the
red carpet skills so i just think thanks
just
hold it down josh
no you really were amazing it is like
that it was very bad boy on the carpet i
appreciate that you got it
you